hello everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I have the treat of
welcoming the team behind a little
prayer to the studio hello and
congratulations on your movie thank you
thank you so much all right
you need to get you to do synopsis
duties I have a feeling you're going to
get asked this a lot so this is good uh
good training for the millions of
interviews you're going to do but can
you tell our audience a little bit about
what a little prayer is about sure it's
about a man living in Winston-Salem
North Carolina who tries to protect his
daughter-in-law when he finds out his
son is having an affair the man's played
by David strathairn and his son is Will
Pullen and his daughter-in-law is Jane
Levy and his wife is Celia Weston job
well done you're off to a great start I
was reading that you started working on
the screenplay in 2016. so what would
you say is the biggest difference
between how you envision the film
turning out back then and what you wound
up with in the end what an interesting
question
um yeah gosh I mean it went through a
lot of different uh permutations but uh
you know you dream a certain dream and
then you claw your way towards the
finish line and
um I can imagine uh you know a better
cast
we shot where I where it takes place in
my hometown in Winston-Salem so um I
can't really tell you if how it's
different than what I envisioned it it's
just that it that it exists at all is
great every single film is is a miracle
and again I know this took a little bit
of time to get off the ground over the
course of like that particular process
of getting a green light what would you
say was was the low point a time that
made you think like Dan this might not
happen and had you overcome it yeah no
there were two or three times where it
was just completely dead in the water
and I had other producers who just said
we can't get this made and they left and
then the great Lauren vilcek came on and
said there's always a way and then Max
Butler came on and
um and you know covet happened which was
a big thing uh which put everything in
purgatory for a year and a half at least
so um all of those things which I'm sure
is the story of every film this year at
Sundance and it went through the same
thing there there's a lot of that and I
I've asked this at a couple others who
encountered those kinds of challenges
and I don't like looking for Silver
Linings in the pandemic but I I do find
that when you strip away the things that
you're used to having while making a
film you could find new corners of your
craft that you wouldn't have been able
to had you had all those things that
you're used to so for each of you is
there anything new you discovered
because of not having those typical
things on set
I don't think you have a good answer for
that question
[Music]
gosh well I feel like uh because of
covid we were there pretty much the
whole time we shot so that
for all of us I think in different ways
we got to explore Winston-Salem a little
bit which was it's certainly helpful for
me to kind of just like take in the town
and the area and the nature and the area
to kind of put it all in our like
Collective DNA was super helpful that I
just think
probably with busy schedules and before
covid we would have been more in and out
so that was a really nice thing we got
to have
these intimate families and
what on the surface looks commonplace
and
um the dreaded word average but then he
finds what's unique about them and
beautiful and intimate and their
struggles are Monumental to them and he
he gives us those characters to play and
um it's uh it's a gift to have them
see I know you worked with Angus before
what is something about his work as an
actor's director that stayed the same
and what's something that he did on a
little prayer that made you go like wow
I never realized you were capable of
that well um just repeat what you said
he's an actor's director and I was
saying I've said this earlier that I
think he's a beautiful writer and um but
that he uh is also
an actor and he honors that and he and
those that he invites to be with him and
he looks to their ingenuity
he wants it depends on it invites it and
that's that's you know like uh like
Bonanza time for an actor I love hearing
that will and Jane I'll throw that one
to you to expand on that a little bit do
you remember a time on this set when
angus's approach to directing his actors
invited you to bring something else that
wasn't maybe originally on the page
I'm not sure I can think of a specific
moment but something that is so special
and moving to me about Angus as a writer
and a director is that he it feels as if
he has profound respect for the
characters he writes and you know the
characters are flawed as all humans are
but there's no like
political or moralistic point of view
that he's trying to he just lets people
be and in their humanness like I find
them to be I I love these characters so
much and it makes playing them
really meaningful I they're you know
they're humans with a lot of need and
um I just feel really lucky to have been
a part of this
yeah I don't I don't know that there was
a specific moment Angus and I were
trying to figure out in the car when
exactly we first started
talking about the film and I just felt
like since that first it was over Zoom
the first time it it felt like this
really gentle collaboration where there
was a lot of room for both of us to ask
questions and explore together so by the
time we got to set something was like a
year and a half later there was a real I
felt really at ease
um because there's a lot of darkness in
this film so it's really like a
vulnerable
place to be so I feel like Angus did a
really fantastic job of letting us all
feel safe taken care of at ease to
explore those darker areas of all the
characters Angus kind of uh leaning into
what they both described someone brought
up recently the idea of movies having a
participatory quality and I really
appreciate that where the filmmaker
isn't judging anything they're laying
out full stories and letting the
audience assess for themselves so how do
you maybe go about achieving that which
I think you do do here but also making
sure you give your audience a full
experience through the story yeah well I
I am an actor was an actor for a number
of years and I was always really
frustrated when a role you just had one
or two things to play I always want to
create characters that have a wide range
and you don't judge them you know you
you see their weaknesses you see their
strengths you see their charm you see
their evilness if they have that
so that's really important to me and
also once I became a film director I
really understood how vulnerable actors
are on screen that a director can really
make you better and worse than what
you're doing and you just sort of bling
yourself out there and Trust
so I really feel for actors because I
I'm one of them and that's just really
important to me and that's why I really
love actors I mean there are so many
great films with non-actors and that I
love but I really love working with
actors because they can hold more than
one thing at the same time and express
lots of different levels at the same
time
um and so I generally and and Drawn to
actors
who you know are trained who know what
they're doing and also almost always
have some sort of sense of humor which I
think is fundamentally important even if
it's a dramatic piece or not
you have quite the Ensemble here we
obviously have to talk about David I'm
going to throw this year away what is
something about him as a scene partner
that you appreciated and maybe helped
bring something out of your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to without him I just felt very
safe and
um
again I don't know why I keep using this
word but respected by him and
um there was just uh so much
we had to create a pretty Like Loving
intimate Bond quickly because it's an
independent film we don't have a lot of
rehearsal time and a lot of days of
shooting and I just found his talent and
his kindness to to uh you know make help
me be a better present actor in my
scenes it turns out also he's from my
town that I'm from
um I wish he was here
I lived in the same New York City
apartment building as him for a little
while when he was doing a show and
that's just like that's my claim to fame
I live in the same building for a little
while and I saw a show and it was great
um bringing up the idea of not having a
whole lot of time here I guess for for
each of the actors maybe what particular
scene did you want to carve out the most
time for yourself to prep for and then
Angus for you of everything on the
shooting schedule what did you want to
make sure that you left that kind of
wiggle room open for
uh I think um
especially for for the character of
David uh Angus and I had spoke about
finding the moments in the film where we
really get to see him and not the sort
of character he's putting on for the
world so there's a scene
um of him leaving the factory with his
with his dad that from the beginning we
had we had talked about and there's two
scenes with his dad where
um David sort of drops his facade and is
is really vulnerable and allows briefly
to himself to be seen by his father
um so that was for Angus and I talked
about that a lot and we really for me a
lot of the prep work was to build
to that moment and have that moment kind
of live throughout the entire film that
senior referenced is great no thank you
thank you how about for you Celia well
it was with David as well
um it's towards the end of the film and
it's um
the most cataclysmic scene they have and
um I liked that
we see throughout the film that they are
partners and their friends and they have
respect for each other and they've built
something they're proud of and this was
something that I felt my character
uh could not had to shake him
to understand what had happened to them
really the ramifications of it and
um and the tragedy of it
and that was an altercation
but you know they made it through it and
it's not the first one they've had
I feel like I know which one you might
go for
yeah so uh
interestingly enough we shot the scene
where my character is in the doctor's
office
uh having an abortion the day that the
Supreme Court reversed Roe versus Wade
um
and you know as actors
I think we can all relate you have a
scene in any project that you're about
to work on that you have a lot of
anticipatory anxiety about you're like
oh this is the scene that I have to
deliver this and oftentimes we put
pressure on ourselves that don't need to
be there so for this scene I was already
like you know I have my own
baggage when it comes to this subject
and I just
felt it was you know it's sort of You
could argue that my character's climax
is at the end of this the movie I think
it's uh this scene where she's in the
doctor's office but anyways I had all
this
tension and anxiety about the scene
never knowing that uh that that
piece of news was going to come out so
anyways I was in the green room again
it's an independent film we didn't
really have green rooms or like holding
areas and I I was waiting to shoot the
scene and I got a text from my mom and I
I guess I'm naive but I really wasn't
expecting that at any point
um and so that scene
there was a
Collective grief and rage that uh
I I don't know I can't believe that that
timed out that way life meets over I
vividly remember everything I did that
day so to know how it lined up with the
work you were doing that I can't even
compute how you would put yourself
through that well I have to say I was
really grateful I feel super super
grateful that I'm an artist and that I
get to you know
uh make
movies with the with these uh
feelings and you know when we're
shooting when we're doing this today
tomorrow is the 50th anniversary of Roe
versus Wade and then we premiere on
Monday
so it's a really strange
reality that we're dealing with
I still can't wrap my head around that
reality
I wanted to ask you a little bit about
your visual language on the Celia when
you were discussing you're seeing one
scene that popped in my mind that that I
loved and it's so it's so simple but it
fills out their world it makes it feel
full is when you go into Patty's room
you're collecting all the laundry and
then you just decide to put it down a
lot of the movie has moments like that
where it's just letting a character do
their day to day having people come in
and leave frame what was it like
figuring out the right way to capture
this family and how they operate well we
have I had a great cinematographer Scott
Miller who I adore and he was the only
one really I felt when we were making
the film who understood what I was
trying to do I drove the continuity
person a little bit because she'd say
well you didn't catch this and I'm like
no I I want it to just be we did a lot
of Runners I mean we just did one shots
and that's because I love actors and I
love seeing behavior and I also there's
a lot of filmmakers who I really adore
like genre Noir and you know Mike Lee
who who like long takes so that you can
see behavior
um so that was a real intentional thing
and for me to answer your other question
I mean what concerned me was the most
was in terms of having we didn't have
any wiggle room were scenes where there
was like there's like 11 scenes in the
kitchen and I was like oh my God how are
we going to do that and a lot of them
are like the early morning routine that
these people have done for years and we
had no rehearsal and so it was like
choreographing who goes where especially
Jane who had to like make breakfast and
fill pill jar pill boxes and have
dialogue and do everything and she's
incredible at this I mean I would give
her you know it would be like the
morning and I'd say okay now you got
over here because I've mapped it all out
in my head and you're going to make this
and take the lettuce over here and then
you put it in here and then go here and
you go here's a bag and make sure the
bags don't wrinkle too much because the
sound person will be mad and then sit
down and do this and she'd go okay and
then she just do it
yeah I can't even remember my own daily
routine on a regular basis so I'm
impressed that you could do that
I just finished a TV show where I had to
learn dance choreography so all right I
mean she said she had to learn a song
and choreography every week and I
thought this training paid off
exceptional and Zoe's extraordinary
playlist I'll keep blabbing about that
show because I want to will more into
existence thank you you don't get
nominated for an Emmy and not do more
yeah I mean I feel that way I have two
more questions for you and I will warn
you my last one is the silliest thing I
will have asked this entire Festival
before I get to that one though
so I am a big cheese ball and I find
that we don't say good job to people in
this industry nearly enough so on this
film whether it is an actor on camera or
someone behind the scenes can you each
name someone who just absolutely crushed
something about their work and you want
to say good job to them
well I um I I mean all of them
and you know I just completely believe
in that that the fish stinks from the
head and that you know the director can
set a tone where people are appreciated
and not just I was a an actor and then a
screenwriter for a long time and you got
treated like when you're a
screenwriter generally and I had been
and I just felt like when I became a
director everyone is important and
you're you you're always trying to
capture lightning in a bottle you never
know how it's going to turn out but for
the hour 19 days that we were together
why does it have to be miserable and I
feel like when I was an actor you do
your best work when you feel safe and
you feel appreciated but I do have to
say that really Scott Miller to me was
just a yeoman I mean he's the calmest
person and he I had never worked for him
before my cinematographer and he with
Island have an idea and it wasn't quite
his he would the most gently
suggest his and if I said no that's not
right to go okay fine and he would
interpret it there was one scene with
Celia where we were shooting upstairs in
like 98 degree without
um you know without air conditioning and
we couldn't get a like a the dolly
wasn't high enough so we had to stand on
boxes and and like Bend his knees do a
plie a deep plie to get this shot before
it goes down close to her and he's
sweating he's pouring sweat and when I
watched the footage too I was like
what's that sound and it's him breathing
so heavily with the camera on his so
he's he's my uh most valuable
player on the on the shot on the scene
yeah he was as temperament was
delightful
there was a lot of students from
College
the University of North Carolina School
of the Arts we're both alumni yes
all right and thank you
there's a lot of
drama school well the
the students that were working on the
film were incredible and they were like
learning on the job and I'm so grateful
for everything that they contributed
yeah I would I would say our crew
um
they made so much with so little and it
was it was everything was so
it didn't feel this way
um I think because of Angus and our
producers and the crew's attitude but it
was really just a tight we had no room
and to no wiggle room
and so to see them all moving and a lot
of students within the crew like it was
one cohesive organism you know that like
I you know all I had to do was walk in
and pick up a juice so I got to sit and
watch everybody you know and it was
really amazing I mean and everyone just
had the best
added to you know there was never it was
always just
everything felt really kind and
respectful was a was a word that a good
word I would say
um and I'll just also mention David
strathairn who is everything you
imagined him to be I mean he's a
complete Mensch and involved and spoke
to everyone and never like
went away and always his questions were
in actors questions and and his he just
was
you know you're supposed to not meet
your idols and I wouldn't say he was an
idol but he really lives up to what you
imagine and I really needed also for
that character for someone who you could
believe was a man of great
um rectitude and and respect and gravity
and trustworthy who's trying to do his
best and he not only is a terrific actor
but really a terrific person he can't be
here because he's doing a one-man show
called remember this the lesson of Jan
karsky in Poland
so that's why he's not here it's a
pretty solid reason to not be here right
now it's a good question I want to keep
thanking people but I know we don't have
time I I really could do it all day long
that's why I keep repeating that
question at a lot of interviews now
because I really am I'm a big believer
we don't say good job to other people
but I also get this feeling like we all
don't say good job to ourselves enough
and celebrate the things we're proud of
I would go down the line and say one
thing for everyone right now but I have
to say quickly to trust for and respect
for
for this guy because I've known him for
so long and he just has endless faith in
me and
um you know just the the honor to get to
as he's working on something his his
um reaching out to to share it with me
for thoughts and um you know I have a
few honored by that all right are you
guys ready for my last question
yeah but first I want to say good
giggling I want to First say good job
you're doing a really good job you're
going to take that back after I
had we had a debate earlier in Sundance
and I was looking for an excuse to ask
this and the only reason I have an
excuse is because there is a scene where
there's a jar of peanut butter at the
center of a scene it's a very important
question the last question I'll ask at
Sundance 2023
you have to make a peanut butter
sandwich what goes on it
I want everyone's answer I mean jelly
whoa
I gave a judging face yes yeah oh it
would have to be strawberry jam okay
okay pollen is all fruit and you know
Smuckers
all natural peanut butter yeah I'm
scared of what you think
mine is actually rye toast with peanut
butter and then I heat it in a frying
pan just to get it all smooshy and then
I put olive oil on it and then I have a
serrated knife and I make even Cuts like
that then I go like that so then I have
little
you asked the right person yeah that is
a great answer that now I have to try
it's a good peanut butter thing I want
what she's having but I but I would say
I have from Asheville North Carolina
from Biscuit Head Jam from a place there
so it'd be peanut butter and jam and
grill grill in the pan for sure
for the record Celia's answer kind of
lines up with mine I got
heavily criticized because I am a peanut
butter fan and sometimes I think that
the jelly takes away from the peanut
butter so it's a plain peanut butter
sandwich there you go salad now that
we've settled this I can end my Sundance
interviews for this year but I will say
huge congratulations on a little prayer
thank you so much for coming by the
collider Studio thank you thank you for
having us